- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is Ignore the Little Man.
Over to you, Kate Winslet.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Ent-spresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning ♫
- When I was younger, when I was only 14,
I was told by a drama teacher
that I might do okay if
I was happy to settle
for the fat girl parts.
Look at me now.
So, what I feel like saying
in those moments is to,
you know, any young woman
who has ever been put down
by a teacher or a friend or even a parent,
just don't listen to any of it,
because that's what I did.
I didn't listen, and I kept on going,
and I overcame all of
my fears and I got over
a lot of insecurity,
and just keep doing it,
and keep believing in yourself, you know?
That's what I felt like I
really had to dig deep and do,
and so I would dedicate
it to all those you women
who doubt themselves, because
you shouldn't be doubting.
You should just be going for it.
- If you're trying to do
something big and important,
then you're going to have
people who are going to try
to tear you down.
It's going to happen.
If you stand for something important,
if you have a big mission that
you're trying to accomplish,
then you're going to have
people who you stand against.
You're going to have
people who are in your way,
even if you have the most
noble, positive mission.
You look at mine, Believe.
Right? Like how do you hate on Believe?
How do you hate on believing
in people to do amazing things?
There's no negativity in my message.
I'm not making videos
about how people suck.
It's intentional to make
everything positive,
and, honestly, to the
detriment of my channel.
Like I could get way more views
and subscribers and comments
if I was antagonizing people
and telling people that they suck.
I don't want to build
that kind of channel.
I don't want to have that kind of vision
for what I'm building,
but even then, even though we're staying
on the positive always,
we get people who hate the message.
We get the little man,
who is going to hate
and attack people,
and say that what they're doing is stupid,
and so, no matter how big or how positive
a thing is that you have to do,
that this is what you're
taking a stance on,
you're going to have people
who just don't like it,
and it's their issue more than you.
They had something in their past that
is coming up, and they don't
want to see you be successful.
It has nothing to do with you.
It's all them and their issue.
See, I see entrepreneurs
as heroes, you know?
I see entrepreneurs,
we're about to take our at-bat, right?
We're in the stadium.
We've been practicing.
We've been working to
get to the major leagues.
We've been grinding and hustling,
and this is our chance, right?
This is our chance to do something,
and 70% of at-bats in baseball,
70% of at-bats are out, for a good hitter,
for the best hitters in the world.
They will only get a hit 30% of the time.
That happens to entrepreneurs, too.
Most of the things that
we try aren't amazing.
Most of the things that we try don't work.
I've thrown away, I've
tried and thrown away
more ideas than most people even start,
so expect to get out a lot.
Expect to get a lot of failure, right?
But finally, we've made it.
We've got our big at-bat.
This is it, right?
Maybe we'll get a single.
Maybe we just get to first base.
Maybe we get a little bit of contact.
We get to second base, we get a double,
and maybe, maybe this idea
that you have right now,
maybe this amazing
thing that's inside you,
maybe the timing is just right.
Maybe the execution is just right,
and you see that pitch counting down.
This is your moment.
All that hard work, all that practice.
This is your time.
Right?
And you smash the home run.
That's what we want.
That's what we've been
working so hard for.
That's what we put up
with all the failure for,
to hit that home run,
to run around the bases,
to celebrate, to do something
meaningful and impactful.
Who's the little man?
The little man is the
guy just watching you.
guy up in the stands,
buying his Crackerjacks, buying some beer,
and yelling insults at you,
and telling you that you suck,
and telling you all the reasons why
you're never going to hit a home run,
throwing popcorn down at you,
saying go home, go home, you bum.
That's what the little man is,
the people who are too afraid to get up
and go do something themselves,
the people who are too
afraid to put in the work
to get their at-bat.
They're going to bring on
everybody else around them,
and maybe they took an at-bat once.
Maybe they took their shot.
Maybe they tried to
believe in themselves once.
Maybe they had that idea
and they tried to do something with it,
and they failed, and it didn't work out,
and the story they tell themselves now is
it's never going to work.
And of course, it can't
be their fault, right?
It's not their fault.
It's somebody else's fault,
the economy, the government,
the president, schooling,
lack of resources,
lack of money, whatever it is.
It's always somebody else's fault,
and because they didn't have success,
now you can't either.
Look at the people in
your life who are hating
on your idea, really
hating, like the little man,
the people telling you
that you can never do this,
the people who are
really stomping you down.
Have they done what you are trying to do?
Whatever your mission is,
whatever your ambition is,
have they done what you are trying to do?
Have they hit the ball
like you want to hit it?
Have they hit their
home run in the same way
you want to hit yours?
Have they done it?
(inspirational guitar music)
Stop listening to them.
They are cancer.
The more you spend around those people,
the more you believe what they believe,
the more you become one of them,
the more that big idea that you have
gets further and further from reality,
and you start thinking oh,
that was really stupid,
and you become like them,
and then you start dragging
other people down as well.
Don't do that.
Don't pay attention to the little man.
Create a better environment.
Change your friends.
Change your resources you consume.
Change the videos that you watch.
Create a morning routine
and a ritual and a habit
that sets you up for boldness, every day,
'cause you got to put in the work
to get your at-bat.
You got to put in the work,
and even when you get there,
to the major leagues,
you're going to get out
70% of the time.
Doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter that you failed.
Doesn't matter that the
fans are booing at you.
Doesn't matter they're
throwing peanuts at you.
You want to hit that home run?
You're ready.
Believe.
So the question today is: I'm curious,
who has been the little man in your life?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Katrina Megginson.
Thank you so much, Katrina,
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
Really, really, really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read,
so thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Ent-spresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Ent-spresso keep me going ♫
(typewriter clatters)
♫ I keep on falling
♫ In and out
♫ Of love with you
♫ I never
♫ Loved someone
♫ Way that I love you
♫ Oh baby ♫
When I sing that song, every night,
I'm like wow, like who'd have thought
that all of this from
that, you know what I mean?
And you know, people told us that was
a bad record to go with.
Nobody plays, you know, slow records.
It'll never cross over.
Nobody's going to get it.
You won't make it, dah dah dah.
I mean, they told us
everything under the sun,
but it felt good and it felt special,
and when people heard it, they were moved,
and you know, all the
pieces just fell into place,
so it's definitely, you
know, my calling card.
It's like my little baby, you know?
And I cherish and respect it.
- Yeah, don't let cool people
tell you you're not cool,
'cause they're not cool,
so, you know, I was a loser for, you know,
by stereotype for many years,
and it's like the classic
case of look at me now,
you know what I mean?
So, I mean, let me tell you something,
if you're out there right now,
and you like have no idea who you are
or what you belong to,
it took me,
I don't know, man.
I just figured out last year.
Last year was the first time I ever like
looked in the mirror and
was like I like that guy.
It took me 25 years,
and you know,
I don't know.
Don't listen, don't listen to
what the cool people say, man.
They're not cool.
Do what you do.
What you do is cool.
- Ignore people telling
you your idea is bad.
They may be right, but
the only way to know
is to actually build it out,
and I think the thing that
works about Silicon Valley
that's different than Mexico City
or almost anywhere else in the world
is the default response,
if someone says hey,
I'm going to start a
startup, here's my idea,
the default response is to be excited,
and think like, oh, why might that work?
And in most of the rest of the world,
the default response, when
you tell someone your idea,
is to say oh, that's not going to work,
and this is really toxic for startups,
'cause you have to believe in yourself,
and the good ideas, because
they sound like bad ideas,
are so fragile and so killable,
that you have to be really careful
to insulate yourself against this.